[Music]
in unnecessary arrests news submitted by
hey [ __ ] a grandmother is outraged
after finding out her six-year-old
granddaughter was arrested for throwing
attention yes we were at the beach we
were at the beach in Hawaii and then me
and Ty cords just dig in like Aloha mean
take us okay so I remember just thinking
a halt right there is this other family
next to me that kid was maybe three to
four about the kid Shane right now
what kid Shane yeah he's about to say
like I'm a better parent my kids
chilling shaming their own kids we're
not [ __ ] up but I found out that this
guy was a fan we're just talking in his
time I watched like family vlogs and
stuff him all cool and then then I see
his kid throw like the biggest tantrum
in the world he just jumps up and pretty
much like gold holds on to the full to
the floor slabs herself on the floor and
it's causing the biggest scene and he's
alright he's like dragging him through
the sand and I'm looking at him and I'm
like damn it never gets easier huh any
of those so what are you supposed to do
throw them in the water we did five
minutes later then we're walking away it
was electric Beach where we're leaving
and Tyga is this [ __ ] doing the same
[ __ ] we just keep walking with him he's
like and we're like it was just funny
because when you is were washing him he
was going super crazy I just thought it
was funny he belongs in jail right okay
so this like I'm not [ __ ] kidding
this toddler was arrested I don't think
six is a toddler but first grade a
little kids to two for a toddler I think
so for one thing that matters the point
is it's a little
that should never be a first grader he
thinks Canada had already been reading
for three years at things like
definitely a deserve to be arrested
definitely first grader has two years of
education
two years of education you should have
been first year they all they did was
just take a nap yeah well and you
learned the left scissors from the right
scissors 27 and I still consider myself
a toddler yeah but you look like going
sizes 1 so let's go what happened with
this kid
except for that girl it's mostly from
the grandmothers perspective so you had
to actually go to the police station and
pick up their six-year-old child the
grandparents are taking care of them
because there was an altercation at
school in country Americas oh this is in
Florida okay that's your home there
there was an altercation there was an
altercation at school and they don't
have a whole lot of details about what
exactly happened you know protecting the
child's privacy they're nice I know
there really wasn't just six-year-old
that's a certain year old that got held
back they're like you can't be 7 no no
no you guys look up back to 6 I wonder
if this was a Samoan six-year-old who's
like 10 feet tall already know they well
there's a video of her but we can kind
of just look at it so you guys could see
what she looks like but she kicked
somebody so that's assault that's not a
tantrum Wow
getting arrested for kicking somebody
even though it's a six year old is much
different than you just screaming truly
six-year-old doesn't believe no I do
know but that's different than just
sitting there like screaming entwine
flat-footed just straight to the chest
it'll just knock 300 this is sparta the
kid was actually arrested handcuffs put
in the back of a police car station
fingerprinted and among school way do we
have video though we don't have a video
the tantrum but what I'm saying it's
like one good Leonidas kick actually I
think impacts the child more than being
the salt now yeah you can't get me for
the night or you could grab both ankles
with your feet and then flip them upside
down and shake them so the kid kicked
another kid yeah and then the gut they
got arrested and put in the back of a
car baby
literally eruption so they don't have a
mugshot of the kid but I can pull even
play a little of this video just so you
can like see what the child looks like
how do okay alright but yeah you can
like it's just the interview of the
video but you can see what she looks
like she's just a little [ __ ] kid now
what this that's how she's acting now
though yeah cameras on like she's a
little kid like come on Booker my thing
is like did like not a single cop was
like what age is bookable cuz I got
arrested when I was 12
what would you do it rate and you can
say hey that's still a punk what did you
do boy I stole some [ __ ] you should have
been a I got a restaurant on the back of
police car unless you're like evading or
like you're just like kickin and you're
being unreasonable where is it fun but
that's so like that what's the
difference between that and a tantrum
because you stole your beer an adult you
can my mom's love well no I'm saying
with this in this situation the the
officers are adults bacon like like calm
her ass down you know or like speak to
her in a certain way unless she's like
running away in [ __ ] maybe I don't think
they needed the mug shot or the [ __ ]
thumb print 0 through 6 are the
formative you what if they were doing
that to scare her but I feel like a
six-year-old wouldn't comprehend what
like how serious being booked
is yeah I've been arrested at 13 and
when do you do you think what would have
been more impact scared straight that's
good well my mom wanted to do that to me
when I was a kid I'll show you and I
didn't qualify I wasn't bad enough no my
mom wanted to take me to scared straight
because she thought I was going down the
wrong path and like I just didn't really
qualify like they had to take up
inventory with kids that were like doing
heroin at 13 what did you do to
Oh graffiti I don't know I feel like 6
and 12 and 13 are way different
yeah and then in the headline of a
tantrum is also a way different than a
girl kicking a girl not that it's way
worse but I think of a tantrum like
screaming on the ground and [ __ ] I
don't think you're failing you're
kicking people like that maybe changing
her put her nose to all that was our
punishment if we did that would be way
more punishment then like getting to go
in the back of a cop car and then I
think where it happens and who was
around like if the parents aren't around
and the girls just run through a mall
kicking people is more of a crime kind
of like what you like you yeah I'd like
stealing is a crime graffiti is a crime
processor though like because what
they'll mostly do is they'll get the kid
and put them in the back of a cop car to
just kind of like yeah scare them a
little all the parents have called the
parents have them pick them up actually
yeah your prints on them yeah like
processing a child is kind of weird
that's really also like there's so early
in your life you're developing like your
identity and who you are and you've now
just taught the six-year-old child
you're a criminal
like you've just taught them that this
happened at school and then they call
the cops yeah well that's just [ __ ]
weird
what's the list a crime or whatever
you've heard of a kid going to juvie for
dealing stealing goes you know what's
weird is that keep it stealing you don't
there'll be bloody fistfights
that go down and the cop might come and
just talk to the kid or whatever at high
school but no one gets booked for that
[ __ ] so this is pretty excessive well
you know maybe city right cuz like LA
how many fist fights are happening high
school a billion how many in like butt
[ __ ] nowhere Florida maybe nothing
yeah like and also to me like it's such
a big scandal because I imagine how
embarrassing that is in front of the
other kids this provides like getting
[ __ ] boy clay either you like embrace
it and you think you're badass but then
you probably become a criminal
or you you know I am I don't know I
don't really go with cops I'm too scared
you wait is anyone have y'all been
arrested
they just said 12 or 13 basically well I
mean I got a danger boys did
gee you you never been arrested I don't
think so I think you would know I can't
remember I think once never been
arrested innocently I was pull I've been
pulled over twice before once for a
headlight and then once cuz I was lookin
pretty good if you could count how many
times you've been pulled over then
that's pretty remarkable yeah oh yeah
cuz countless times I pulled over
alcohol the Asian die real Asian guy in
an Asian car a description of a thug so
oh I see okay I got profiled at one time
before I was in Sherman Oaks is it like
and like I dunno I just look to you yeah
I am from Sherman and Sherman Thomas in
Sherman Oaks
and I was with a friend of mine who was
like a black guy who's just like a tall
like kind of bigger looking black guy
and we were standing outside of the
apartment waiting to go like for a
friend to come out and this like old
white dude pulls up and he was like what
are y'all doing and I was like just
waiting for a friend and like my friend
like he knows exactly what's up I've
never been profiled before and he's a
cop no he was just there yeah he was
just there and he was like we were like
Oh waiting for an uber and then he why
he's like oh okay we was like then I
guess you don't mind if I just wait here
until you're over pulls up and you leave
and I was like I do [ __ ] mine and my
friend had to tell me to like Chuck cuz
like I've never been profiled before
like it's never happened to me before
and I was like damn the struggles that
the black man goes through I felt it man
pulled over his profile yeah wait well
we had the baldhead yeah yeah that
happened to me like once but went up it
was nighttime so like it's not because I
was white but I bought an $800 Cadillac
when I was in high school and it was
like a 1983 big old caddy you know look
like a piece of [ __ ] and my dad was
driving us to a basketball game gonna
had two bucket seats and so like the
whole team's in there there's six dudes
and we're all like juniors and seniors
in high school you know so it's six
dudes in this Cadillac
rolling through a whatever neighborhood
and my dad just like didn't use a
blinker or something but same thing they
came out with lights and a guns it's
like 7 o'clock at night and then sees
like my buddy my best friend is sitting
in the middle of the back bucket seat
he's drinking tea because it's like his
pregame ritual
like [ __ ] freaking out cuz he's
trying to sip his tea we're like what
the [ __ ] going on and then you just
like that's my dad like why'd you turn
so fast or something stupid saw that we
were just no why did he turn fast with
the guy during a tea and the bad and
then that was it that's like my craziest
things with cops
dude if I pulled somebody over and like
I thought they looked suspicious and a
dude was in the bag drinking tea I was
like that's not tea I don't know I don't
know why they're so weird but yeah I
just try to avoid things like that
someone a bit risky I love that his
pregame ritual is drinking tea out of it
was a big old buck you have a weirdo in
the car to go no it wasn't a bug it was
like a bug thank you guys go to the
parties I came in we're all great ritual
mug I ever had a pregame ritual is that
like a thing play sports what do you
play sports pregame or game like a
literal game not to drink the trinket to
keep I'll talk about like you guys were
going out to par my dad the druggist
friend and that's why I don't know
pregame like that came from the term
from but never about to get his head in
the game that's where it started from
that's why the party people took that
yeah because it's before the game I
didn't feel that when we were bonding
earlier I didn't feel the party ah it's
it's died down I'm getting old bones you
getting all the can't drink with the
kids and yeah it's pretty much over
pregame ritual
you
[Music]
you